nous allons parler justice nous allons
parler juste ici je reçois l'avocat du
diable
jacques vergès
maître vergès bonsoir en soi dont vous
publié chez michel lafon
un livre qui s'appelle omar m'a tuer
histoire d'un crime se dire quoi omar
m'a tuer c'est vous qui avaient été tués
par romain ces personnes ouais la phrase
est ridicule et les tragiques
elle ne concerne pas omar et c'est pour
ça que je les prix c'est l'histoire d'un
crime c'est l'histoire de ce qu'on a
fait aux mares mais pourquoi omar ne
serait-il pas coupable omar ne serait
pas coupable pour une raison simple le
corps a été découvert le 24 juin à 8
heures du soir
le médecin est venu il a constaté les
signes sur le cadavre
parmi les quais parmi ces signes a les
yeux clairs les yeux clairs indique que
la mort ne remonte pas à plus de 6
heures à 8 heures si nous sommes à huit
heures du soir
la mort remonte au 24 juin lundi 24 et
le 28 juin il ya eu une autopsie fait
par trois médecins
ils ont constaté les mêmes choses au
mois de novembre les trois médecins ont
déposé un rapport rendant la mort
remonte au 24 juin entre 11h30 et 14h et
puis au mois de décembre mais c'est tout
ça ça ne collait pas parce que omar le
24 juin à un alibi en béton
il est dans sa famille à toulon alors le
15 décembre les trois médecins disent
c'est une erreur de dactylographie qu
aucun des trois n'a vu et la mort en
fait est antérieure 24 heures seulement
ce n'est pas une erreur de
dactylographie parce que si on a fixé
cette date 24 juin c'est à partir de
constatation qui elles ne sont pas
erroné donc omar n'a pas pu tuer madame
marchal 24 jeunes parce que le 24 juin
ils n'étaient pas là et il a malgré tout
été condamné à dix huit ans et a malgré
une révision criminelle
malgré les circonstances atténuantes et
là encore on constate quelque chose de
bizarre
madame marchal est une dame de 65 ans
elle a toujours été très gentille et
comme à l est tué de cinq coups de
chevron c'est à dire un petit madriers
sur le crâne
ces cinq coups ont été portés avec une
telle violence qu une phalange et
découpé quand elle se protéger que son
dentier plutôt son bridge a été projeté
le meurtrier lui apporter ensuite quinze
coups d'une arme blanche sur le corps
depuis le coup jusqu'à la cuisse le foie
le ventre une blessure de 15 cm et les
entrailles dehors un crime pareil ne
mérite aucune circonstance atténuante
cissé lô mars et perpète or on lui a
donné les circonstances atténuantes des
circonstances atténuantes exprime le
doute des jurés mais dans toutes les
sociétés civilisées quand il ya un doute
on acquitte qu'on ne condamne pas à
moitié
donc pour vous il n'est pas innocent
jusqu'à preuve du contraire il est
innocent pour moi il est innocent mais
qui a tué alors madame marchal alors qui
a tué il faut poser la question à qui
profite le crime
madame marchal était une veuve elle
était séparée de son mari monsieur
marshall depuis une quinzaine d'années
elle était séparée de lui ensuite il est
mort ils n'ont pas divorcer elle est
milliardaire elle à domicile en suisse
et la luxueuse maison de mougins n'est
que sa maison de campagne
il ya quelqu'un à qui le crime va
profiter
nous ne savons pas qui on n'a pas
cherché dans ce milieu c'est vrai qu'on
a trouvé une enfant n'a remarqué plus
tôt une voiture immatriculée en suisse
charles berling arrêt près de la maison
oui mais plus que ça le lundi 24 juin un
ouvrier tunisien qui travaille sur un
chantier voisin et qui de temps en temps
peut se reposer regarde peu aux
alentours voit une voiture volvo
immatriculé en suisse
s'arrêter devant la maison de madame
marchal en descendre un homme de 35 ans
environ avec des cheveux blonds hilson
et une voix à l'intérieur demande qui
est ce et à ce moment là lui 120 1 or si
une voix qui répond à l'intérieur c'est
madame marchal
donc elle est vivante de lundi matin et
cette voiture
cet homme on n'a pas cherché à savoir
qui c'était parce que dès le départ on
avait décidé que c'était le petit
jardinier marocain
on a dit vous le savez que s'il a été
condamné c'est parce qu'ils étaient mal
défendue par vous oui écoutez ça quand
on veut défendre une décision de justice
on met tout sur le dos de l'avocat 1
mais quand les juges de los angeles a
quitt les trois flics qui ont lynché un
conducteur noir on dit pas s'ils ont été
acquittés c'est la faute de l'avocat ou
ont dit les juges sont racistes parce
que là on s'en fout on dit la vérité
mais pourquoi ne pas avoir utilisé
plutôt votre fameuse stratégie de
rupture c'est à dire de remettre en
cause la légitimité même du tribunal un
avocat ne fait pas de la rupture quand
le dossier est un dossier qui n'est pas
de rupture quand je défends des les
prisonniers du fln c'était un procès de
rupture c'est des procès politiques bon
tandis que dans le cas d'omar y avait
dans le dossier suffisamment d'éléments
pour plaider simplement devant des jurés
et leur dire mais voyons il n'y a rien
et
et essayer de convaincre les jurés et
donc ne pas faire d' incident mais
discuter simplement calmement du dossier
et c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi cette
stratégie qu'on appelle de connivence et
à dire discuter du dossier simplement
omar haddad celle affaire dreyfus pour
vous c'est pas tout à fait la sphère de
réfugiés évoqué l' affaire dreyfus il y
a des rapports il ya des différences
aussi dans l' affaire dreyfus l'opinion
était contre des refuges et dreyfus et
ses amis ont dû se battre 12 ans pour
faire admettre son innocence dans le cas
d'omar raddad ce qui est bien c'est que
l'opinion et de son côté 48 heures après
65 % des français pensent que le procès
n'a pas été équitable
donc voilà une différence c'est
l'attitude de l'opinion
maintenant dans la cour d'assises même
si j'en crois le journal vsd acquis des
jurés se sont confiés
cinq jurés sur neuf c'est à dire la
majorité était pour son acquittement
et c'est le président qui pendant cette
heure les a travaillé jusqu'à en faire
craquer 2 pourquoi pourquoi le président
a des préventions contre les arabes
eh bien les phrases qu'il a dit au cours
du procès quant à la femme de marc
haddadi omar ne ferait pas de mal à une
mouche par une fine allusion au
sacrifice du mouton pour la fête de
l'aïd el kébir il a répondu oui mais il
égorge les moutons alors que c'est pas
vrai d'abord il est gorgé des moutons
est un rite religieux et deuxièmement
omar haddad n'a jamais et gorgés de
moutons mais la part cette fine
réflexion concernant un accusé musulmans
et maghrébins il essayé de soulever le
racisme et la peur de l'autre
enfin quand on a essayé pour salir omar
haddad de prétendre qu'il avait eu des
rapports et des prostituées ce qui a été
un échec mais le président en a profité
pour dire à sa femme mais c'est interdit
par le courant or est-ce que le
président aurait dit un accusé français
breton ou auvergnat qui trompe sa femme
que c'est interdit par l'évangile notre
manière naturellement une ré pas d'islam
donc il ya là des réflexions qui tendent
à rejeter omar raddad comme un autre
comme un étranger est capable de tout
vous défendez aussi jean edern hallier
et autres affaires
oui que plus mondaine oui contre la
directrice du monde des livres
oui josyane savigneau qu'est ce qui l'a
fait jean et d'un année il ya un
contentieux entre eux il ya eu des
campagnes de bond contre jean edern
hallier à la fin jean edern hallier
s'est mis à attribuer des noms d'oiseaux
à la responsable du monde des livres
il a dit entre autres qu'elle avait je
reste je cite les phrases qu'il a dit
qu'elle avait le clitoris querelleurs
elle l'attaqué pour ça et quelques sons
entre eux puissent santé le lisier way
qu'elle avait des cuisses de grenouilles
cellulite euse et grenu way et il a fait
allusion à des vacances qu'elle avait
prises dans l'île d'oléron avec une
autre dame ray et moi j'ai répondu mais
écoutez vous l'accusez d'homosexualité
dans un de vos articles d'ailleurs c'est
un vrai lui vous accuse de mots
sexualité vous êtes kit vous dans d'une
manière assez plate et vulgaire vous
dites que son ouvrage est nauséabond et
sans mauvais lui d'une manière plus
littéraire dit que vous sentez le lisier
je ne vois pas du tout où est la
différence sauf dans le talent et le
style enfin clitoris querelleur je
m'interroge
j'ai interrogé des gynécologues aucun
gynécologue n'a jamais vu un clitoris
querelleur
[Applaudissements]
mais quant à faire je ne pense pas que
ça soit complet une critique uni une
injure
l'injure reid aura été de dire qu'elle
avait un clitoris new way
non ce n'est pas le cas et qu à ce
moment là donc c'est une fausse querelle
qu'on lui cherche on a des photos du
clitoris
bien sûr tout le monde a droit à un
avocat même même klaus barbie
mais là il se trouve que c'était vous et
ça vous a été beaucoup reproché vous a
coûté cher d'abord défendu barbie ça m'a
coûté cher non ça m'a rapporté beaucoup
d'un jeu ça m'a valu la considération de
beaucoup de gens assez inattendu des
gens qui sur le moment certainement dû
se dire c'est pas bien ce qu'il fait et
qui ensuite quand ils ont eu à se
défendre on dit bert finalement séduit
qu'on va prendre parce que quel que soit
son client il se bat pour eux et il est
pas poltron donc finalement l'effet a
été bénéfique
c'est vrai que ça nous a coûté une série
sur tf1 oui je sais vous le savez
piocelle
j'avais signé un contrat tout était prêt
et puis le contrat a été annulé
pourquoi pas avoir défendu touvier le
droit à un avocat lui aussi écouter
parce que c'est pas l'avocat que choisit
le client c'est le client qui choisit
l'avocat et puis donc tout vienna pas ne
m'a pas choisi la choisit mais trémolet
de villers qui est un excellent avocat
et puis en plus je ne veux pas en faire
une spécialité non plus vous auriez et
surtout que vous étiez illustré dans l'
état de cause
vous auriez plaidé la même chose qu'eux
trémolet de villers en france il existe
deux principes fondamentaux qui date de
la nuit des temps là c'est au bout d'un
certain temps ne poursuit plus les créé
dans un but d'apaisement social l'autre
c'est une c dans la déclaration des
droits de l'homme on ne peut pas
appliquer à d fait passer une loi qui
leur est postérieure vous vous rendez
compte à quel point ça serait terrible
on peut suivre et dans 5 ans en vertu
d'une loi comprendrait dans cinq ans des
gens qui se font avorter aujourd'hui dès
qu'il fonde également c'est pas possible
ça crée une trop grande instabilité on
ne sait plus où est la loi
ces deux principes on renonce à ses
principes pour faire ce genre de procès
est-ce que condamner touvier valait la
peine de renoncer à ces deux principes
essentiels
je crois qu'on peut re en discuter je
vous citais quelques clients célèbres
vous allez me dire si vous les auriez
défendu puis peut-être qu'elle quelle
défense vous auriez adopté louis saez
chez défendu depuis 16 jours à la télé
quelle défense avez vous adopté la
défense que j'avais adopté c'est de dire
au conventionnel
j'admire beaucoup saint-just et
robespierre mais de leur dire écoutez
c'est à une manière de régler les
problèmes politiques que de couper le
cou à l'adversaire parce qu'il arrive un
jour où là où d'autres adversaires vous
coupe le cou ce que tard yeux et c'est
arrivé
staline staline bien sûr parce que plus
l'accusation est grave plus la défense
est intéressante vous l'aidez quoi pour
défendre staline
j'aurais dit aux gens qui le poursuivent
si il n'avait pas mener la guerre contre
hitler ou seriez-vous aujourd'hui et il
clair justement vous l'auriez défendu si
la vie était d'accord avec mon système
de défense qui aurait été quoi qui
aurait été que hitler est né dans une
société allemande
humilié par le traité de versailles le
traité de versailles a été très injuste
envers les
et les réparations qu'on exigeait aussi
des cela a provoqué une grande
frustration chez les allemands et c'est
sur la base de cette frustration qu'il y
a eu une réaction nationaliste qui a
amené de l'est ça ne peut pas marcher ça
mais aucune de ces défenses n'aurait
marché ces défis c'est des affaires
jugées d' avance bref us dreyfus
forcément landes rue mais l'ordre bien
sûr bonsoir monsieur reddition je suis
venu de constater que soixante dix ans
après la condamnation à mort on ne
m'oublie pas non pas du tout voulait
nous nous rejoint bientôt ça va saigner
fonctionne en faisant de jacques vergès
se landru que vous si vous maître
jacques vergès un avocat très très
fameux à notre époque vous pouvez vous
vous présenter landru ory désiré landru
52 heures à mon actif plus de 300
conquêtes féminines et à mon passif
seulement quelques petits creux enfin
vous avez quand même découpé dix femmes
en morceaux et brûlant votre chaudière
est un jeune garçon et soyez prêts si
monsieur ardisson je suis maniaque vous
le savez bien dommage que vous n'ayez
pas été là vous auriez certainement été
un très bon très bon défenseur mais
après vous auriez vous accepté sur moi
alors comme vous savez on a retrouvé
dans mon jardin des os calcinés des
dents et surtout un carnet sur lequel je
notais les frais de voyage de mes
victimes au seulement des allers simples
alors quand ils vous plaidez coupable ou
innocent lui a coûté vous aviez à votre
procès le comportement d'un innocent je
ré plaidé l'innocence
d'autres personnes qui sont innocentes
ont des comportements de coupables par
et ils sont gênés dans leur défense mais
vous vous étiez très habile vous aviez
une défense d'innocents vous vous étiez
convaincant la présence d'ossements dans
votre jardin de prouver rien finalement
et les billets simples signifie
simplement que les bed restez chez vous
ou faire la grasse matinée pendant que
vous rentriez à paris vous êtes rassurés
oui ça ne m'étonne pas nous on ne met
pas les gens dans des chaudières ont les
dématérialise ici mettez vous bien au
fond de votre fauteuil
fermez les yeux or jacques
c'est la première fois que vous
rencontrez landru oui en chair et en os
oui grâce à vous est-ce que vous pensez
que vous êtes le meilleur avocat de
france n'ont sûrement pas ce que je
voudrais qu'on dise de moi c'est que
j'ai apporté quelque chose de nouveau et
que je ne suis pas comme les autres ça
c'est sûr alors je suis complet pendant
de nombreuses années vous avez disparu
on vous a posé de nombreuses fois la
question vous n'avez jamais répondu je
pense pas que vous allez me répondre ce
soir j'ai été dématérialisée pendant
quelques années
oui donc je vais vous dématérialisée à
mon tour d'accord parfaitement
mettez vous bien au fond du fauteuil
fermer les yeux
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu